statt
da
es geht
kulturplatz ich bin hier gerade am
strand von ipanema in rio de janeiro
genauso postkarten tauglich will sich
brasilien in einem halben jahr
präsentieren
beim anpfiff zur fußball wm o2 unter dem
slogan alle im gleichen rhythmus aber im
land des samba ist momentan nicht alles
im takt
im letzten sommer geschah das
unerwartete
ausgerechnet im fußballverrückten
brasilien kam es zum protest gegen die
wm
millionen gingen auf die straßen
verlangt mehr geld für spitäler und
schulen statt für ein teures spektakel
also die wm als katalysator der soziale
spannungen zum vorschein bringt wir
machen uns jetzt auf den weg und
befragen kulturschaffende zum umbruch in
der brasilianischen gesellschaft
was brasilien durch die wm zu verlieren
droht erzählt uns der künstler ernesto
neto wir besuchen die krone des
brasilianischen fußballs doch wer hat
heute noch zutritt zum legendären
maracana sie spielen shakespeare in der
favela diese jugendlichen wünschen sich
ein besseres brasilien die wut des
super-stars sänger kreol ort nicht
vergessen dass er von ganz unten kommt
und schließlich erklärt uns
schriftsteller louis woo vater warum er
brasilien trotz allem liebt
im stadtteil copacabana wird das
brasiliengeschäft dient müssiggang
körperkult und die leichtigkeit des
seins
brasilien hat aufgeholt heute ist es die
sechs größte volkswirtschaft der welt
rund 40 millionen menschen sind in den
letzten 15 jahren in die mittelschicht
aufgestiegen
und jetzt soll diese erfolgsgeschichte
durch die weltmeisterschaft gekrönt
werden
der brasilianer ist bereits in position
in diesem stadtteil von rio ist von wm
euphorie nichts zu spüren hier blättert
die fassade
ich bin auf dem weg zum atelier von
ernesto neto netto ist einer der
wichtigsten brasilianischen künstler
seine raumgreifenden installationen
haben ihn berühmt gemacht
er zeigt sie rund um den globus in
washington tokio oder in new york seine
organischen werke sind zum anfassen oder
duften betörend berühren alle sinne
für ns tonetto ist auch fußball vor
allem eine sinnliche angelegenheit wohl
gerade weil er das spiel so liebt fällt
seine kritik an der wm heftig aus ich
hasse die fifa und zwar schon lange
insbesondere seit sie den chef im
maracana aufgelöst haben das ist der
teil im stadion mit den stehplätzen
direkt am rasen in brasilien
wir tanzen samba zu wir bewegen uns an
hinter wir müssen stehen können die fifa
verbietet stehplätzen in den stadien
dabei ist das doch eine kulturelle
fragen ich finde seine absolute arroganz
dass die europäer uns vorschreiben wir
sollten fußball so schauen wie man sich
das in europa vorstellen was brasilien
einzigartig macht könnte durch die wm
verloren gehen befürchtet netto ich
frage ob nicht gerade die wm eine chance
sein könnte
das allgemeine gefühl hieß dass wir
wirklich eine große gelegenheit
verpassen um die soziale situation
brasiliens zum besseren zu verändern
warum sagen sie verpassen
ich denke das wird nicht geschehen wenn
niemand investiert doch in
ns tonetto ist in rio verwurzelt er
fürchtet um die für ihn typische strand
kultur
denn die behörden haben hier strenge
ordnung verfügt
selbst fußball spielen am strand ist
verboten
doch daran hält sich nun wirklich
niemand und weil ihre messer ein
sicherheitsrisiko darstellten müssen die
traditionellen kokosnuss verkäufer um
ihre existenz fürchten
ich frage ernesto neto warum fußball
überhaupt so wichtig ist für brasilien
ganz einfach fußball vereint die
brasilianer mischt sie zusammen wir
fühlen die sehnsucht nach einer
buntgemischten und doch geeinten nation
das liegt in unseren wurzeln
fußball als einheitsstifter brasiliens
dieser mythos wird jetzt in frage
gestellt ausgerechnet die wm macht sich
war wie brüchig die brasilianische
einheit ist das legendäre maracana einst
das größte fußballstadion der welt
200.000 menschen fanden hier platz die
am dramatischen wm final 1950 als
brasilien den titel uruguay überlassen
musste
auch in diesem jahr wird der wm final im
maracana stattfinden
im neu renovierten stadion gibt es nun
80.000 blitzblanke sitzplätze
noch nie gab es so viele spielorte an
einer b m12 nämlich noch nie waren die
kosten so hoch
man rechnet mit mindestens elf
milliarden franken
eine investition in die zukunft bringt
die wm die erhoffte wachstum und
aufschwung
vieles ist bereits in bewegung geraten
im vorfeld der wm zum beispiel die
immobilienpreise in den favelas zieht
die bauspekulation an
seit spezialeinheiten der polizei die
favelas befriedet und die lokal und
roben könige vertrieben haben
stattdessen kommen jetzt die touristen
die favela wie die götter ist wunderbar
gelegen mit panoramablick auf ipanema
denn die liga lebt der schauspieler und
tänzer marciano radio gearbeitet mit
jugendlichen die uns ausschnitte aus
ihrem theaterprojekt vorführen werden
zunächst aber führt uns maßlos durchs
quartier
die immobilienpreise sind regelrecht
explodiert und hier soll tatsächlich ein
fünfsternhotel entstehen
dieser ort ist perfekt zum leben für
jene die schon immer hier waren aber wie
die gal die vorstädter weit weg sie kann
sich das leben hier nicht mehr leisten
marcia wenn jugendliche aus den favelas
wurde waren auf die schiefe bahn zu
geraten
darum möchte ihn mit seinem
theaterprojekten eine beschäftigung und
eine perspektive bieten und ihre
begeisterung für theater ist riesig als
erstes steht eine szene aus der
widerspenstigen zähmung von shakespeare
auf dem programm
für mich jedes mal wenn ich shakespeare
höre bekomme ich hinhaut seine werke
sind ehrlich gut und stark ein anderes
stück verarbeitet die gewalt in
beziehungen
ich bin das sprachrohr oder frauen
vielleicht ist es eine utopie aber ich
wünsche mir dass die gewalt an frauen
aufhört das ist ein sehr aktuelles thema
unseren favelas
theaterspielen mache selbstbewusst und
mario wünscht sich dass schwarze in der
brasilianischen kultur mehr widerhall
finden
oktober also kultur ist in brasilien
sehr elitär und den theatern in den
reichen fertigen trifft man nur ältere
weiße menschen der oberschicht schwarze
sind nicht zu sehen
und wenn schwarzer im theater und film
vorkommen dann meist stereotyp meine
schwarzen schauspiel freunde spielen im
fernsehen banditen und sklaven offenbar
gibt es keine möglichkeit den anlegern
zu kommen
aber wer weiß vielleicht spiele ich mal
einen anwalt in einer telenovela zur
hauptsendezeit
ich glaube daher welchen platz haben die
schwarzen in dieser gesellschaft in
selbstbild brasiliens gibt es eigentlich
keinen rassismus
in einem bereich des brasilianischen
lebens haben die schwarzen deutlichen
einfluss hinterlassen
in der musik der rhythmus von rio ist
der samba
diese musik hat ihre wurzeln in afrika
und erinnert eigentlich an 300 jahre
sklaverei
rossi auf dem weg in eines der
angesagtesten samba lokale von rio
sogar ich als green gaga ein tänzchen
mit unserem tonassistent
die brasilianer haben den ruf besonders
fest freudig zu sein
vielleicht um sich zu trösten gemäss der
brasilianischen redensart wenn alles
andere versagt tante samba
frühmorgens am strand in copacabana
ein sehnsuchtsort für die reichen und
schönen
aber nicht nur der strand gilt als der
ort wo sich alle brasilianer begegnen
wir treffen eduardo da silva er ist
einer der wenigen fischer die noch in
copacabana die netze auswerfen
tagsüber verkaufen eduardos
berufskollegen ihren fang direkt vor den
luxus hotels am strand
gleich nebenan entstehen imbissbuden
getränkemulti es werden hier während der
wm die massen bewirten von der commerz
fälle werden die fischer wohl nicht viel
haben sie sind zweckoptimistisch wir
werden die spiele im fernsehen verfolgen
die geräte sind zu teuer die
bessergestellten können es sich leisten
ins maracana zu gehen unser 1 wird
solche preise niemals zahlen können aber
egal wie man bei uns sagt uns gehört
dabei wir werden eine gute
weltmeisterschaft machen
wir werden wieder gewinnen und es wird
viele neue arbeitsplätze geben und die
welt wird die gelegenheit bekommen
brasilien kennen zu lernen
welches brasilien werden wir
kennenlernen
letztes jahr ist etwas ins rollen
gekommen
die menschen wehrten sich gegen einen
aufschlag der bus fahrpreise in sao
paulo
20cent daraus mehr sind für
kleinverdiener bereits existenziell bei
milliarden in die wm fließen hieß es an
den demos gehe nicht an die wm
die fahrpreiserhöhung wurde rückgängig
gemacht ein erfolg doch der unmut blieb
es geht um mehr um volksrechte und
mitsprache in einer modernen demokratie
und tschüss graffitis christ
andere dies könnte
linda fr sie
sie verstauten er hat das lebensgefühl
in sao paulo auf den punkt gebracht
creole sein vater ist schwarz seine
familie stammt aus dem armen nordosten
aufgewachsen ist er in einer favela er
weiß was es heißt ganz unten zu sein
heute gilt er als einer der wichtigsten
musiker brasiliens
apa
wir fragen creole ob die proteste
nachhaltige wirkung haben werden wenn du
siehst dass eine mutter für ihr kind
einen schulplatz bettelt und dieser
platz nicht existiert wenn du siehst
dass dein freund in einer notfallstation
im sterben liegen und es keine
möglichkeit gibt ihn zu behandeln weil
es am nötigsten fehlt
die wurst fw und wenn du dann siehst wie
viel öffentliches geld versickert
millionen milliarden
dann wirst du realisieren dass dies
keine vorübergehende welle von
demonstrationen ist die vaters nein es
ist ein meer von fakten
das uns zum aufruhr zwingt jetzt zu
sagen wir protestieren kommt ist ein
bisschen ein
wir brauchen die wm nicht als anlass um
über die missstände in brasilien zu
reden
wir können jeden tag darüber reden
brasilien ein zutiefst gespaltenes land
in der wirtschaftsmetropole sao paulo
mit ihrem 20 millionen einwohnern
prallen die gegensätze aufeinander
big money an der avenida paulista
und direkt daneben unter der
straßenbrücke keine obdachlose familie
so nah liegen die welten geografisch und
doch berühren sie sich mehr nutzt die
luxusmeilen sauberer erscheint uns eine
geschlossene blase
die menschen hier gewinnen die wm vor
allem positives ab
wir begrüßen die wm
denn die investitionen in die
infrastruktur zeigen dem ausland dass
brasilien bereit ist solche grossanlässe
durchzuführen
im stadtteil etat der ein sauberer wird
gerade sehr viel investiert eine ring
autobahn eine neue metro station die
baustellen sind riesig kaum vorstellbar
dass in einem halben jahr hier alles
bereit sein muss auch das stadion für
das eröffnungsspiel der wm ist erst halb
fertig vor einigen monaten stürzt ein
cranachs stadiondach zwei arbeiter kamen
dabei ums leben
richtig abgeht treffen die rationierung
almeida der filmemacher und philosoph
ist einer der treibenden kräfte des
bürgerkomitees in allen austragungsorten
haben sich die anwohner in solchen
komitees zusammengeschlossen um gegen
menschenrechtsverstöße zu protestieren
etwa gegen zwangsumsiedlungen nicht dass
asche miro gegen die wm wäre er
kritisiert die rahmenbedingungen
anderthalb milliarden werden in diesem
stadion gerade verbaut einem spital von
ithaka hier in der nachbarschaft fehlt
es an allem nichts dagegen dass man die
wählen durchführt damit geschäfte macht
aber wenigstens nicht mit unseren
öffentlichen geldern mit dem geld dass
jeder brasilianer mit seinen steuern
bezahlt und außerdem wie ist es möglich
dass die fifa die partnerfirmen nike
oder coca cola die gewinne nicht
versteuern müssen dieses geld gehört
auch unseren dieses geld wird hier in
brasilien gebraucht
wir sind unterwegs im urbanen dschungel
von sao paulo ein unwirtlicher
lebensraum
doch überall im beton gibt es zeichen
der rückeroberung durch die anwohner sao
paulo hat eine überaus lebendige street
art szene künstler wie oc - die diese
wand gestaltet haben sind mittlerweile
weltberühmt
eine von vielen unbekannten
kunstschaffenden ist layar sousa sie
schlägt sich mit auftragsarbeiten durch
wie hier an der mauer eines
privatgrundstücks
leider kommt aus einer der ärmsten
provinzen und will in sao paulo als
künstlerin anerkennung finden
ein schwieriges unterfangen
es ist als ob ich jeden tag einen löwen
töten müsste wie man in brasilien sagt
aber mein wunsch meine arbeit zu zeigen
nicht zu entwickeln
außerhalb meiner heimatstadt zu malen
war wirklich so stark dass es mir wert
ist alle schwierigkeiten zu überwinden
die lehrer würden wohl viele
brasilianerinnen und brasilianer von
sich behaupten dass sie jeden tag einen
löwen töten müssen er erzählt vom
täglichen kampf mit bürokratie
korruption und des organisation hilfe
von der politik können leute wie sie
nicht erwarten
wir lieben brasilien brasilien hat viele
qualitäten aber unser land wird schlecht
regiert dabei hat unser land potenzial
hat zukunft
ich glaube an ein besseres land für alle
brasilianer
ich glaube an veränderungen
veränderungen gab es schon für millionen
von brasilianerinnen und brasilianer hat
sich das leben etwas verbessert dank dem
wirtschaftsboom und den sozialprogrammen
von ex-präsident lula mit dem neuen
bescheidenen wohlstand wachsen nun auch
neue bedürfnisse ein rapper den wir
zufällig treffen tut uns seine meinung
zur wm kommt ich bereite mich auf
unserem letzten interview partner vor
den schriftsteller louis ruf wartung
er wuchs in einer armen migrantenfamilie
auf mit einer analphabetin als mutter
der vater ein popcorn verkäufe heute ist
louis wo vater einer der wichtigsten
schriftsteller brasiliens doch was heißt
das in einem land in dem 30 prozent der
bevölkerung nicht richtig lesen und
schreiben können
für rosa tor ist daher bildung der
schlüssel zur zukunft brasiliens dass es
den brasilianern heute wirtschaftlich
besser geht sieht er nur als teilerfolg
42 millionen menschen sind vom elend in
die armut aufgestiegen
diese 42 millionen gehörten vorher nicht
zum kaufkräftigen teil der gesellschaft
aber sie sind keine bürger geworden
sondern konsumenten noch fehlen die
bedingungen dass sich diese menschen
wirklich an den gesellschaftlichen
entscheidungen beteiligen können
brasiliens demokratie sei noch jung und
den brasilianern fehle ein
zugehörigkeitsgefühl sagte vater das
merkte er vor allem bei den protesten
ich erinnere mich dass ich bei den
ersten manifestationen sehr
enthusiastisch man also dann überraschte
mich wie unterschiedlich die forderung
es der forderung die ich auch vertrag
etwa die nach besserer bildung
daneben aber gab es leute die die
einführung der todesstrafe verlangt
und wieder andere wollten tatsächlich
vergünstigungen für hundefutter dass
kein scherz ich habe das selbst gesehen
das war kein auftritt für gemeinsame
ziele
es war ein kollektiver ausdruck
individualistischer wünsche paradox
estland sie beschreiben eine gewisse
hoffnungslosigkeit trotz allem leben sie
hier was macht brasilien für sie
lebenswert
es ist ein reiches land
in jeder hinsicht rohstoff die strände
der karneval die papageien und nach
allem klingt das jetzt vielleicht cool
wir brasilianer gegen den grossen wunsch
nach einer gesellschaft in der
chancengleichheit herrscht wenn wir das
einmal wirklich schaffen und dafür
kämpfe ich dann wäre brasilien eines der
besten länder der welt möge sich luisa
vaters hoffnung erfüllen und so stoßen
wir an auf die zukunft brasiliens mit
einem gläschen zuckerrohrschnaps
das mal
das wars also von unserem brasilien
spezial zum jahresauftakt nächste woche
begrüßen wir vom kulturplatz sie wieder
in der schweiz ist ein wünscht eine gute
zeit
und 19
wasser
galler
weil er schon